scrolling is the new
smoking be careful how you use your
smartphone
we've got a reminder for you you can
download the free scrolling is the new
smoking wallpaper
over at theminimalists.com
does one ever really heal from grief
hmm nicole does one ever heal from grief
my first question um again i want i'd be
interested to hear you know what jenna
what her definition of healing is
this is another area where we're all
subjective
you know so what what does healing mean
for for you you know does it mean not
feeling any version of the sadness and i
think it's pretty clear that in terms of
you know our discussion here sadness and
grief are going to be part of our human
emotional experience
so whether or not you release it from
the thing that you're grieving in this
moment
chances are there'll be another grief
that comes
up so if the question was can i abstain
from grief for the rest of my life the
answer to that is no
yeah but um it sounds like what you're
saying is we can figure out how to
better
lack of a better term deal with grief
yeah
um it's like a scar sometimes it's like
it's always
yeah going to be there so it's like how
are you going to deal with that scar
this makes me well scar is is by
definition healed right
well but there's still remnants of
the wound right but it is but maybe what
you're saying then is grief has healed
but
in in that case uh it has healed as best
as it could
but it'll never go back to the way it
was before
right right we won't go back to the womb
so to speak right
the life has been lived at this point it
makes me think uh
we were in tokyo a couple years ago me
and mariah we were visiting with some
friends
and we were on the subway and it had in
japanese like this writing with a
picture
of a man in a trench coat and we were
like what the heck is this
so we pulled the google translation app
and we like hold it up
which blows my mind by the way that you
can like hold up i know
and then it just in real time it augment
reality like changes it to english blows
my mind
uh that's a different conversation but
essentially the way it translated which
was probably you know a bad translation
but it said something about
uh do not expose yourself to women on
the train
because you will you will leave a scar
on their heart and i was like
this is actually really deep like
yeah really poetic and it just makes me
it makes me think about this question of
grief because
yes we get these scars on our hearts and
like maybe
they healed um but yeah we're never
gonna go back to the womb there's still
remnants there
it's a matter of yeah how do we hold
space for those
for those scars